the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode
good morning everyone and welcome to
investor expo show
for july 9th my name is anna and i'll be
your host today
we are having a great lineup of three
speakers for you
michael walters for the first time on
our show
sid norris and jason love
this session will be recorded and sent
to your email
please take a look at your goats webinar
control panel
into the questions box you will be able
to ask any questions you want
during the speaker's presentation
so let's begin and bring to the show our
first guest
michael walters good morning michael
unmuted good morning anna how are you
today
perfect how is your day going so far
it's good it's good
you know it's uh summer's here and uh
about halfway through it and i'm
enjoying it i'm enjoying
being able to go outside and things like
that
um always love your presentations
what are you planning to share with us
today well today
i got a special presentation i'll be
talking about uh
order flow techniques that work you know
everybody always wants to have
um you know strategies that work in the
market and i'm gonna be sharing some of
my
personal my favorite strategies that i
use on a regular basis
every day in the market so you know
hopefully people can come away from
today's presentation
with a good understanding of things that
they could apply to their trading
and how to read the order flow
sounds great and exciting i will get
back to you in 45 minutes
okay great okay let's make sure my
screen is
showing okay looks like it is
all right uh let me just get going here
so
hey everybody uh welcome to today's
presentation my name is michael baltos
from orderflows.com and today i'll be
talking about order flow techniques that
work you know
we all want to have
ways of trading the market that work and
today i'll be sharing
a few of my strategies that that i use
on on a regular basis things i look for
every day
in the market so you know ask yourself
you know as a trader
you know is this you you know are you
trying to put
a square peg into a round hole you know
and what i mean by that is you know are
you losing money you know are you doing
things that just don't work you can't
put
a square peg in a round hole and expect
to
be successful at trading now what you're
going to learn today
is i'll be talking about three different
topics you know one what separates order
flow from other market
analysis i'm talking about how to
successfully
trade order flow and lastly i'll be
sharing with you
order flow techniques that work you know
these are techniques that
i use daily you know i'm always looking
for
these setups these patterns if you will
in the order flow
so for those that
are new sorry michael just would like to
remind you that
um please follow the questions
uh from the attendees and uh could you
please make uh
to play your presentations because i can
see the other slides too
you uh okay i play on the slideshow here
i thought i had it on okay
looks great is that better now yeah some
reason is having a bit of a problem with
this pc for some reason
but anyway um it should be okay now
okay
alrighty so let's just see if we got any
things here okay so
for those of you that are new to one of
my presentations um again my name is
michael baltos
and i started this company called
orderflows.com
in 2015. okay so that's what we're going
on about five years already
and what it is it's a order flows
software as well as education company
but prior to that
i've had 20 years in
institutional trading at the highest
level right i spent eight years
as vice president of futures training at
jpmorgan i spent four years
as a futures trading desk manager at
cargill
i spent three years at commerce bank as
a ux trader i spent two years
at edf mann as a global macro trader and
i spent three years with dean where i
started on the cme floor as a runner
which is you know basically the the
lowest level that you can start
in the business and
you you just you don't have that
level of entry nowadays that you had
before and so
by starting my company it was a way for
me to give back the knowledge that i've
gained over the years
that people can apply to their own
trading and
like i said you know in 2013 i left jp
morgan because i want to spend more time
with my family
i wanted to trade for myself you know
trading does give you that freedom
you know you don't have to be a slave to
a nine to five job you could go out
there
you can live your life you can do your
trades
and if you're good at it and you can
make money you know that's what can
um provide for your standard of living
and i wrote a book it's called trading
order flow if you stick around to the
end
i'm going to give you a copy of my book
trading order flow now
with the order flows.com you know i
i realized that the trading software out
there that looked at order flow
wasn't good enough and i wanted more
from the software you know i wanted the
software to do um
analysis for me rather than just present
the data there for me you know computers
are there to help you
understand what you're looking at in the
market
so i met with a programmer who
understood order flow
and we created the order flows trader
software it runs on ninjatrader eight
and what it is is a volume footprint
chart with seven pre-programmed order
flow indicators
and the charts the reason i talk about
this now is because i want you to
understand the charts that you're going
to be seeing in this presentation are
generated
specifically from the order flows trader
software which runs on
ninjatrader 8. now brief disclaimer
please understand that trading
involves risk and you shouldn't be
trading with money you can't afford to
lose
so the first topic when we talking about
is what separates order flow from
other market analysis
and again it takes us back to the basic
question why do most traders lose money
well from working with a lot of retail
traders over the last several years
and i found that working with retail
traders as opposed to trading
in an institutional environment is
completely different
retail traders mainly focus on one part
of the market
and that one part is just price right
they only
focus on price and to me that's that's
the big problem
now if you remember yesterday in the
e-mini s ps
we had a big move down we had a big 30
point move down from
you know the 31 62 area down below 3130
and move happened you know relatively
quick in about an hour
okay and you know as a trader these are
those moves that you love to catch you
know you love to catch the big
20 point move the big 30 point move but
often times
you know people get in well after a move
has started so
let's just take you through some ways
that
people that focus on price
get into the market and i'm going to
show you how people that look at order
flow get into the market so
okay price action traders right they're
going to see a
lower low lower high lower low then the
break of the lower low they're going to
get short
okay that's fine you know they
fortunately this was a big enough move
that there was a lot of profit that
could be had right if you're getting
short around the 3150 area
and covering around the 3130 area that's
great that's a nice 20 point move but
remember
the move started above 31.60 you just
gave up one third
of the profit potential head and
shoulders you know classical
technical analysis
pattern and it's very similar to
the price action the lower low lower
high lower low
you have your two shoulders you have
your head you break the neckline you
know again coming in
around 31.50 by this time by the time
you're breaking 31.50
everybody in the world is seeing this
market breaking
so you know while it's not a bad trade
to take
again ask yourself where you want to be
short from do you want to be short from
10 points lower now if you're into
fibonacci right
you had a nice 50 percent retracement
here coming in around the 3156 area you
know you could have got short there
and you know caught a nice move down so
you know all these forms of technical
analysis when the market is trending
they're all going to kick off nice sell
signals because there's so much juice
so much meat on the market that
no matter how you get into the market
you can make money you know and this is
sort of
one of the
i don't say downfalls but you know one
of the ways that traders get lulled into
the market is when you have a nice big
move
anything you throw on your chart is
going to make your money right again
you know this is the plain candlestick
chart the move starting up 3162
down to 3130 you know maybe you're into
trend lines
okay you got all the spaghetti going on
your charts
one of them's got to work you know there
was a nice one coming up probably around
the
31 right in that box you know the 31 56
31 58 area that's that's a better entry
but then again
you know if you're short from earlier
you took you know you would have been
stopped out on a bunch of trades right
because the market did rally up from
3140 all the way up to 31.60
before falling over you know and then
there's
later breaks again around the same level
around the 3150 area
3148 area that everybody in the world is
seeing
okay but again by that point you just
you gave up an extra
10 points now order flow
was very bearish up near the high
that was being put in around the 31 um
60 area all the way to 3162
areas in that box up there
and this is what the order flow volume
footprint chart looks like right
what order flow does is it takes what's
being traded on the bid in the offer and
it puts it into a nice
easy to read format so that
you could decide you know should you be
is this market strong is this market
weak and this is especially important
because
anytime a market is at a high of the day
you want to be asking is this market
strong
meaning are we going to go higher or is
this market exhibiting weakness
meaning this is the high it's probably
going to hold i should be looking to get
short you know any shorts that i take i
know exactly where my stops are they're
going to be just beyond the high of the
day
you know or even right around the high
of the day you know you can have a much
tighter stop
with order flow than with traditional
technical analysis so when i'm looking
at this
high that's being put in yesterday and i
see
i i put the red arrows there so you can
see the
bars that have multiple imbalances and
i'll be talking a little bit more about
imbalances a bit later
but when i hit the high i see
selling coming in i we hit a new high a
couple you know a point and a half
higher
more selling imbalances come in over the
next couple bars
that's bearish right because what is
happening the market rallied to a high
level
and sellers are being attracted into the
market and not just
you know people yeah i'll throw in an
offer here no these are people that are
hitting
the bid these are selling imbalances
appearing
at the high of the day now
second part that made this high so
appealing
given a low risk trade opportunity is
after hitting the high
just about all the deltas in the bars
are negative
meaning there is more aggressive selling
in the bars than
aggressive buying and that's important
as well because it's one thing to have
just imbalances selling and balances up
at the height of the day
but when you hit the high of the day and
the market is just sort of going
sideways
but overall there's selling
occurring right what's happening you
know everyone talks about accumulation
and distribution but they don't really
get into it
when you see at the highs a day you're
going sideways but you see
overall negative deltas
that's a sign of distribution that means
there's supply in the market people are
happy to sell
at these high prices now remember right
if you got to think as an institutional
trader
somebody that has that's sitting on a
big inventory in this case
we'll call it eagle this is e-minis is a
one-minute chart market is going up
right you don't sell if you're an
institutional trader you're not looking
to sell
as the market starts going down even
though you will participate
but as the market is going up and it
hits a high and it's just sort of
staying around that high
if you can sell as much as you can at
that that those high levels
without moving the market that's a great
sell if you're
a institutional trader if you're a big
trader
you want to sell as much as you can
without moving the market
and what people get lost on
is they don't think like institutional
trader you know and
and i know this because i speak from
experience having to trade big sizes
at the banks is as the market is
rallying
that's your opportunity to move size
right if a market is dropping and you're
trying to sell
a big position you're just adding fuel
to the fire you're helping the market go
down
but if a market is rallying going up
that's the most easiest time to sell out
a big position and as you can see here
right these are the individual bar
deltas
right they're all basically negative you
have a few bars that are positive
in here you know you got one bar with a
250 one bar with 130 one bar with 97
you get that last minute pop that last
pop up before the market falls over of
strong delta 1558
you know people is trying to just see if
we can take this market any higher maybe
trigger some stops maybe
trigger some programs coming into the
market
they make that push it doesn't they
immediately turn sellers boom
delta just expands expands expands
and the market falls over
now another part of order flow is what i
call the internal
deltas right it's the max delta the min
delta
and what the max delta the min delta is
well the start beginning delta is
the difference between net aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in the bar
max delta tells you how positive
the aggressive buying was at one point
in the bar you know how it's strength
min delta tells you the strength on the
weakness side you know how weak it was
in the bar and you can see we're right
up here at our highs of the day
and the max delta as you're just giving
along the highs
from the high to the this new high
before it falls over
you had very relatively small max deltas
you know 99
200 300 100 200 150
35 100 again before that bar with
the you know where it just pops up but
you
at your highs of the day where's your
buyers
right you don't see them in there right
you should be seeing positive deltas you
know on this move up just the bars
preceding
this area where you went sideways you're
seeing positive deltas 400 500 900
then you're at your high you only got
100 200.
you know that's a sign of weakness right
because you don't have that big strong
aggressive buying in the market anymore
now another one another
extra clue is you're at your high of the
day
excuse me and just before nine o'clock
you've got cumulative delta cumulative
delta is
the total strength in the delta or the
total weakness in the delta
throughout the day so you know think of
it you know you're always adding or
subtracting to the cumulative delta
so you hit your high at you know 95 859
okay you made the new high the first
time it's got a cumulative delta of
eleven thousand two one six
okay now we trade sideways
cumulative delta is getting smaller boom
you make the new high
cumulative delta is 11013
so it's a difference of about 200
contracts but you're making a new high
well when you're making new highs you
should be making new highs a sign of a
healthy market
is new highs on stronger cumulative
delta
not weaker cumulative delta because from
their initial high here
we had at 8.59 cumulative delta
eleven thousand two one six and then
over the next
12 13 minutes it went down from 11
000 to 9400
so you know that's almost about a close
to
two thousand uh over two thousand
contract swing
you're still around your highs so what's
that telling you there's a lot of
selling a lot of aggressive selling
coming into the market even though the
market is basically going sideways it's
not selling off
it's because you know people are are
buying from these
aggressive sellers then boom you get the
one bar where you poke up
positive delta but again the cumulative
delta is still negative is still
lesser than the first time you hit the
high then it just starts dropping off
again
over the next couple of bars so
hopefully by now you can understand you
know how
order flow can get you into the market a
little bit faster
right it's going to get you in up here
this it was that area i was showing you
on those order flow charts is this
3160 area so it's telling you the market
is
pretty weak up here all right again if
you're at the high of the day and you're
looking to short you know around the
3160 area your high is 31.62
you got a two-point stop more or less
and look at the potential right as
opposed to you know getting short off of
trend lines off of a
um price action getting short at 31.50
you know head and shoulders again 3150
trendlines
you know fibonacci you know the 3155
area
you're getting a minimum of an extra
five
points on your short of profit potential
and more often than not you're getting
you know 10 points extra
on your on that move so
how to successfully trade order flow
well what's the goal of trading
right it's to make money you know we're
not in here to say i'm the smartest
person in the room no you want to make
money right you want to have a good life
and i that's how you keep score in the
markets
but to be successful means you're making
money consistently
and this is where a lot of traders
struggle is
consistently now in order to trade
successfully with order flow you have to
understand what the data means you're
looking at you know it's like driving
your car you got all these little gauges
they each mean a different thing um you
know
my wife she's a good driver god bless
her
but she doesn't understand what a lot of
these lights mean and you know all she's
focused on
is the speedometer not even the gas
gauge but um
you know rpms forget that but uh you
know
she wouldn't know that hey the car needs
oil unless i sit there unless i see the
light come on say hey you know
the car needs oil can she drive yes she
can drive she's a good
excellent driver but when it comes to
taking care of the car
basically like taking care of your
training account you got to understand
what you're looking at okay now
order flow is about understanding what
the aggressive traders are doing in the
market now
that doesn't mean that's all overflow is
about there's other things about order
flow
but sort of the the main focus on
order flow is determining what the
aggressive traders are doing in the
market
and what they're doing right now so this
is a dome right we're all familiar with
you know the depth of market the price
ladder okay
and you have passive buyers people that
sit on the bid
and below and passive sellers traders
that are on the offer
and above the offer for a trade to
happen
an aggressive seller has to sell to a
passive buyer
or an aggressive buyer has to buy from a
passive seller and when that does when
that happens
when an aggressive seller sells to a
passive buyer that registers as
-1 in the delta and the volume is
printed on the footprint chart on the
bid side
at that price if an aggressive buyer
buys from a passive seller that
registers as positive one
in the delta and that one contract that
traded
or five contracts that will show up on
the
offer side of the footprint chart okay
so
earlier i was talking about delta and
imbalances again delta is the difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in the bar
an imbalance occurs when there are more
aggressive buyers versus
aggressive sellers in the two-way
auction right most trading that happens
there's there's no imbalances okay
majority of trading i'd say about 90 of
the trade it's just your normal market
facilitation
you know buyers and sellers transacting
but there are times when there's
an imbalance of buyers or an imbalance
of sellers in the market
so within order flow there's
four types of delta numbers you could
look at there's the delta which is sort
of like the headline delta which is the
final delta in the bar you know when the
bar at that snapshot in time what the
delta is
max delta is how
strong positive delta was at one point
in the bar
max delta is how strong negatively
delta was in the bar meaning how much
selling the max
selling in that bar at one point
cumulative delta is sort of your running
delta total for the day plus or minus
so final delta it will appear
along the bottom of the bar okay you can
see at the bottom here some people call
it the basement
um but you see there's delta max delta
min delta cumulative delta
and i also have volume up there so delta
again tells you
the delta for the bar so you can see
here at this
low at 945 it's got negative 51. so it's
telling me when this bar closed
there was net selling in the bar minus
51.
the next bar has positive delta of 176.
it's telling me when the bar closed
it had positive delta more buyers and
sellers by 176 contracts
okay so max delta let's just take a look
at these two bars again
max delta in this red bar at 945 is just
seven
so it's telling me at the strongest
buyers were in this bar
it was just seven contracts over net
sellers
okay it it can't max delta can never go
negative
the lowest it could go is zero the next
bar
max delta this big green bar at 946 it
had
max delta of 182. so it's telling me
this bar had 182 more buyers and sellers
at one point in this bar
okay now min delta
again those two bars min delta is how
strong sellers were at one point in the
bar so again at 9 45
this red bar had min delta of minus 134
meaning at one point the
net sellers outnumbered the net buyers
by
134. the next bar it was just minus nine
mid and delta could never be positive
the highest it could go is zero
and i'm not going to get into you know
i've got some other videos on youtube
about the relationships between the max
and the min delta numbers
but these are good numbers to tell you
when a market is turning
now cumulative delta it just is sort of
the running total in the delta so when a
bar closes
you know like you can see here at 9.45
the max delta
sorry the cumulative delta was 4681 then
the next bar
it closed with a delta of 176 so you add
the 176 to 4681 cumulative delta
got bigger to four eight five seven next
bar
69 was the final delta 69 plus
4857 is 4926 you know then as you get
into negative you subtract from the
previous bar
that's your cumulative delta there's
ways to use cumulative delta
in your trading as well but that's a
whole other
webinar now imbalances
they occur when there are more
aggressive buyers versus aggressive
sellers
in the two-way auction remember markets
trade in a two-way auction
31 10 and a quarter bid at 31 10 and a
half
but when you have say more aggressive
buyers trading at 31 10 and a half
versus 31 10 and a quarter
by a certain ratio most people use four
to one
okay which is you know it's a good level
to start it you know but again it's not
set in stone
the minimum i suggest is about three to
one i know some people that use ten to
one
again it's a personal choice but the
average the industry standard
is about four to one okay that's that's
sort of that's my default starting
number
and not all bars have imbalances
now how it looks on a footprint chart
right again the footprint chart plots
the volume traded at
each particular price in a bar now
there's going to be
black numbers red numbers and blue
numbers
blue numbers as highlighted by these
blue arrows are buying imbalances
cell and balances are the red volumes
now normal order flow is the black
numbers inside the bars
again you know some bars have no
imbalances some bars may have both the
buying and selling and balances
but generally when you have green
candles
that's where you're going to see buying
imbalances when you have red candles
generally that's where you're going to
see selling and balances but again
there's no absolute in there now
with buying imbalances the way you can
start to use them is you look for
certain patterns in the imbalances
so for example a stacked buying
imbalance
okay is a bar that has three or more
buying imbalances stacked neatly on top
of each other right
and a stack selling a balance is the
opposite it's a bar that has three or
more
selling imbalances stack neatly on top
of each other one two three four here
here you've got on this binding balance
you've got like uh
eight binding balances in a row
sometimes there are oftentimes
you see them being caused by stops you
see them being caused by big traders
coming in and sweeping the market and
sometimes you just
you know everybody decides to get long
or get short at the same time there's
different reasons
for them being caused in the market
now my order flows trader software takes
it a step further
and we highlight the bars that
have what i call multiple imbalances so
on a green bar it's going to be
three or more buying and balances on a
red bar it's going to be three or more
selling imbalances so you can see here
on this chart
there's no stacked buying imbalances
instead what you have is
multiple buying and balances multiple
selling imbalances
and it puts a pink box around it's
actually violet but
it looks pink and this is important
because it's
highlighting to you areas where traders
are being
aggressive in the market and you know
i'll be talking about this
in the next section you know as a trader
you want to be seeing
areas where traders are aggressive in
the market you know where there's
aggressive buying coming into the market
where there's aggressive selling coming
into the market
because you want to take advantage of it
so you know the last part i'm going to
talk about is order flow strategies at
work now i look for these strategies
every day in the market you know i
cannot open a chart and not look for
these strategies because
i know that over time they've made me
good money
and there's no reason for me not to look
for them because i know that when i see
these
these patterns these strategies appear
in the market i know that
the market has a tendency to go in that
direction
now again please note
right when you trade don't trade in a
bubble like analyzing
one bar and one bar in isolation
you got to look beyond what that one bar
is doing
understand sort of you know the market
overtone
um going on in the background right is
the market trending up
is the market trending down or is the
market going sideways you know if the
market is trending up
and you know think of it like the tide
okay there's you know the tide in the
ocean right it comes in
spends all day coming in and spends the
rest of the time going out
and you have individual waves coming in
at the same time
and you know if you're going to go
surfing you know or go swimming
you know that how to time in when you're
going
into the water right by the waves you're
not necessarily concerned with the tide
but you know if you've ever spent time
at the ocean
and you know the tide's going out and
there's a big wave going out you can
find yourself
sucked out further um from the beach
than you want to be
so you know take market context
into consideration when you're taking
trades
you know just don't take trades blindly
because oh my gosh you know here's a
stack buying a balance i got i got to
take this trade you know understand how
it's being
why it's coming in at the market at that
time so
the first pattern the first setup i want
to talk about today
is the multiple imbalances okay now
what a multiple imbalances i just talked
about it briefly but it's three or more
buying imbalances in an
up bar a green candle or three or more
selling imbalances in a down candle a
red candle
again take it in context of the market
don't just blindly buy
every bar that has a multiple imbalance
or sell every bar that has a multiple
imbalance
multiple imbalances differ from stack
and balances and they're spread out
in the bar now we've had this in our
software for many years as far as i know
we're the only
software that has it the order flows
trader software
and what it is again is you can see here
with this blue arrow you see this pink
box coming in that's telling me i have
three buying imbalances in the bar just
as these red candles have
more than you have the pink box around
it they've got
you know more than three selling
imbalances in there and again you could
adjust you know say you don't want to
look for just three
say you want to look for bars that have
five okay you can do that
just two say you want to look for bars
that have imbalances
but not four to one say you want to be a
little bit stricter i don't know how i
want to use
ten to one you can do that you can
adjust that you know it's flexible
in that sense and again you know when i
say take them in context of the market
this is yesterday morning
or in the e-mini mes right the
one-minute contract
uh sorry the one minute chart mes is a
great contract for trading
because it gives you skin in the game
you know
a lot of brokers have i mean the initial
margin is like
twelve hundred dollars but a lot of
brokers have day trade margins of fifty
dollars a tick is worth a buck
25 and it's a good way you know if you
want to get out of sim and sort of put
real money in the game and get a feel
for the psychology
that goes along with um with trading
it's a great way to get involved in the
markets and
yesterday after we hit our low here at
31 25 and a half
the market started creeping back up and
then
as we started creeping back up i could
see aggressive buying coming into the
market in the form of
buying imbalances and they're spread out
again if you're looking for
stacked buying and balances you don't
see any on this move you're going to
miss this entire
pop-up you know so imagine you're
getting long here 3131
it makes a quick move all the way up to
the 3137 area
you know that's a quick five-point move
in
just a couple of minutes in the mes
okay so here's bonds this is a yesterday
as well it's a five-minute chart
okay people say why you jump around
between one minute and five-minute chart
because if you're looking at a
one-minute chart of the bonds
it's basically oftentimes it's trading
bid in the offer bid in the offer for
one minute um you got to expand it a bit
and i want to show you i look for the
same things
whether it's a one minute chart whether
it's a five minute chart whether it's a
four range chart whether it's
eight range chart whether it's a 500
tick chart whether it's a 5 000 volume
chart you're looking for the same things
in the order flow
this was the bonds yesterday we popped
up to this high
we got a bar with multiple selling
balances you see no stacked imbalances
in here
you know some people they write
strategies they sell you software
looking for stacked imbalances
and they're missing this whole thing of
multiple imbalances
you still have aggressive sellers coming
into the market they're not just not
neatly stacked on top of each other
and multiple imbalances are important
and you see you got a nice move down
there in
the bonds and
you know a little bit later in the bonds
you know after we sold off we made a
move
back up what do you got you got multiple
buying and balances
signaling to you hey aggressive traders
have come and stepped in here
and boom the market puts in a nice rally
this is crude oil it's a one minute
chart yesterday right after the high was
made at 40 78
at just before 8 o'clock in the morning
what do you got
you got a bar with one you know one
minute chart
one two three four selling the balances
then two bars later another bar with
selling of balances
you know this was a quick 20 cent move
that you could have had
in less than 10 minutes in the crude oil
euro currency so again it's a five
minute chart
we're just right around our highs of the
day just sort of sitting there
but as you're at the high of the day
what do you see
you see some bars with multiple buying
and balances but again that's why i talk
about taking things in context of the
market
okay you're at your highest aggressive
buying coming in that's what you expect
to see
but when you're at your high and you see
aggressive selling coming in
yeah your ears should prick up you
should say okay what's really happening
in this market
i expect to see aggressive buying coming
in at the highs and you do see it
now but you also see aggressive selling
coming into the market
okay what do you think is more important
at the highs aggressive buying or
aggressive selling
well if it was just aggressive buying
with no aggressive selling okay
maybe the market could go higher but if
you got some aggressive buying but you
also have
aggressive sellings telling you that
there's
sellers up here we're at a high price
we've attracted sellers into the market
and they're interested
in distributing their supply
so you know we're up here for 30 minutes
and you're seeing one two three bars
with aggressive selling
before the market breaks from 56 all the
way down to 40
to the 30s so
don't just focus on the obvious stacked
imbalances look for areas
on the chart with multiple imbalances
they're just as important and again
you know as a trader right you want to
have an edge
over other traders right you want to
look you want to see things that they're
not seeing that you can take advantage
of
and i'll be honest with you very few
traders look for multiple imbalances i
know some successful traders
that's all they look for is bars with
multiple imbalances and trade around
them
okay so the next
setup i want to talk about is the delta
surge and what it is it's a steady
increase in directional delta
over several bars and again it's best
taken in context of the market don't
just buy every delta surge that's a buy
or sell everyone that's a sell
take it in context of the market you
know as the market is starting to move
that's where it's going to be in my
opinion
strongest now this is an indicator it's
for free
on my website orderflows.com you just
got you know click on the button that
says download
the delta search it's only for
ninjatrader eight
so and it's not available for any other
system just ninjatrader eight
but what it is this is e-mini's mes
rather
so 100 uh 1 000 tick chart
and you can see here just around 12
just after 12 in the afternoon yesterday
you had a delta surge up here
you got a 10-point move down you're
coming up to this
sort of the swing high coming in around
the 3148 area
and then you see the sellers stepping
into the market the aggressive sellers
you can see some imbalances appearing in
the bar with the surge
signals even the bar before it but you
can see here i
circled the box you can see the delta
getting minus
it's positive 33 at the high then it
becomes minus 67
minus 94 minus 700 that's your q2
if you're in a position get out and
start to get short okay because this
move up is over
the sellers have come into the market
and they're
in control right now of the market
again it's the mes this is a one minute
chart
okay right after the high was made this
was earlier in that day yesterday
just after the high was made at 9 12 9
13.
again you got your high and you see
aggressive sellers coming in and you see
that in the delta
it went from positive 1600 to minus 82
minus 304 minus 942
you know the market kind of went
sideways before it just fell off the
cliff right dropped down into the 30s
but again as you're in the sideways
action
there's nothing in the order flow
telling you to
get long it's all negative it's all
selling it's all negative deltas
right here's crude oil
this was a quick a swing high around the
area 40 74 then a delta surge appears
he went minus 12 minus 35 minus 131
and then a quick 15 cent drop from the
60s
down into the 40s this was gold
yesterday
it's a one minute chart again you hit
your swing higher on the 1828 area
delta surge appears market sells off
from
you know the 26 26 and a half area down
below 23.
again and that's within less than 10
minutes
you know the delta minus 6 minus 20
minus 59.
and again you know if you're not using
ninjatrader and you can't get this
indicator you can just look at the delta
on your chart and see that right you can
see the delta is getting stronger or
negative more negative
it's hard to find um buys yesterday
because
pretty much all the markets were down
but you can see here you know you get
the
upper body would be the opposite it
would be 6 20 59 here you see minus 6
minus 20
minus 59. now the beauty of having this
indicator
is it will work on normal candlestick
charts as long as you have ninjatrader
again you can see this is that mes
yesterday right
yeah there was one signal earlier around
745 it didn't work
then you got that monster signal at
about 9 15. then you got a smaller
signal a bit later around 1 o'clock in
the afternoon
here's wheat right this is
a market that was rallying yesterday
rallied into the night session
and you can see you know there was you
know a buy the day before
didn't really work a buy around the
close market went up a couple cells
first one
you know a couple cents next one no
stopped you out
you know nothing is perfect okay
if anybody's going to sell your trading
system this guarantees 100 trades
you know it's it's
doesn't exist um without you got to have
super wide wide wide stops and take tons
of heat that most people can't sit
through but you can see how this market
is moving higher and higher and higher
as it's you know as the delta surge is
is building on itself
so hopefully by now you can see how
orderful analysis provides
advanced information that you need to
gain an edge over other traders
you know you want to see what's
happening in the market so hopefully by
now you can see how powerful order flow
is right don't over complicate trading
trade what's happening right in front of
you so if you're ready to add order flow
trading to your
analysis i've got a special deal for you
i mean but there's two ways you can do
it one you can try and figure all this
out on your own you spend years
looking at a screen trying to figure out
order flow more importantly you could
waste more money trading or two you get
the education
and software from a trader who has
successfully traded
order flow at the highest level you can
skip that massive trading losses
skip the wasted time and order flow
gives you the most current information
available to a trader it's not some
indicator it's just the market
right it's not based on pivot levels
it's not based on fibonacci it's not
based on elliott wave
macd or not v web h what is trading on
the bid
what's trading on the offer order flow
is the market
so there's the orderful trader software
right it runs on ninjatrader 8.
and again all the charts i generated in
this presentation are from
the order flows trader it will run on
the free version so if
you want to you know you don't want to
spend money for the paid version of
ninjatrader you could run it on
the free version but having order flow
software is one thing you have to know
how to use it
i don't just give you the software send
you on your way i provide a lot of
education
i just got an email from somebody
yesterday who bought one of my training
courses
says you know i bought this other
software but there's absolutely no
education that goes with it
and each week i do a private live group
training session just for users
okay so far there's 80 recorded sessions
so it tells you how
long this goes back some people will
charge you extra for this right there's
some people charge
200 a month for additional training i
give you this for free you can go in
there you can ask questions i'll answer
them
i'm in there every week i'm also going
to give you access to the order flow
trading course which normally i sell for
297.
i also give you access to the inner
circle video series there's additional
56 videos on order flow
tricks tips and analysis so you put this
all together
it's ready sixteen hundred dollars
seventeen hundred dollars but
as a special bonus because of investors
expos keeps having me back i'm gonna
give you access to my favorite course
the order flow playbook that's pushing
two thousand dollars but you're not
going to pay that
right and i don't want you to spend more
money than you really need to be people
think that
the the value of an indicator is how
much it's worth like the more it's worth
the better it is no you gotta read
what's happening in the market you know
a lot of people say very good things you
know here sheila says
your order flows trader software is
remarkably helpful i can clearly see now
who's in control of
the markets so
you know if you want to be successful
you got a plan you got to get there
so for a one-time payment just 6.75 you
can get my software
all that education is included in it
there's no more payments you don't have
to keep paying me monthly
you don't have to all you got to pay for
is just your data fees that you pay from
your broker so just go to orderflows.com
off to and it will
take you to the sign up page right
that you can get started
it's takes it looks like this the page
all right just scroll down to this
button that says buy now
i want this
and you know it's processed by paypal
i don't get your credit card information
i don't want your credit card
information right
now if you want my book just go to
orderflows.com book.html i just checked
the link out it does work
so you enter your name email and click
submit it will take you to that page
so go to orderflows.com off to to get
started
right you know anything in life you got
to get started you got to get up off
your butt
and get going so
anyway i'll um put the link in the chat
actually i'm not sure she got it in
there but um
you know the book is
orderflows.combook.html make sure you
put the html on the end
if you're interested in the software go
to orderflows.com2.html this is a
different offer than what's on my
website
my website one it's a more expensive
offer but
you know this is the of2.html
offer is a very good offer to get
started on trading order flow
all right anna i'm going to throw it
back to you now so thanks for having me
and thanks everyone for that time of
your day
thank you so much for the great
presentation we had
all the links into the chat box uh
as always pleasure having you on the
show and have a great rest of your day
thanks anna bye